last time
or no on reddit you said that last time
too
that you don't experience much fear uh
before
fights i'd like to ask you a couple of
mike tyson things if it's okay it's just
interesting to me maybe i'm just weird
so there's a
i don't know if you've seen this clip of
uh tyson talking about how he feels
leading up to a fight that uh he's kind
of
overtaken with fear as he gets closer
and closer and closer to the ring
his uh confidence grows um
have you seen the clip i'm aware of it
okay we've seen in a while here let me
play it for you i think george st peter
said something similar to me one time
while i'm in the dressing room
five minutes before i come out my gloves
are laced up
i'm breaking my gloves down i'm pushing
the lever the back of my
break in the middle of the blood so my
knuckle appears to the left feel my
knuckle piercing against the tight
leather gloves on it
and the last box angle and i come and i
have supreme confidence but i'm scared
to death
i'm totally afraid i'm afraid of
everything i'm afraid
i'm afraid of being admired but i'm just
totally confident closer i get to ring
the more confidence i get
to close the more confidence i get the
closer more confidence i get
all during my training i've been afraid
of this man i thought this man might be
capable of beating me
i've dreamed of him beating me but i
always stayed afraid of him
but it was closer i get to remain more
confident once i'm in the ring
i'm a god no one could beat me i'm a god
i mean first of all he's cognizant of
both his
demons and whatever the hell ideas he
has about violence is so interesting
is there something about the uh
the tension that he's describing about
being confident and scared that
resonates with you
or you're or do you hold to this idea
that you've kind of
spoken about before that you're really
not afraid no i
i can i can appreciate what he's saying
you know i think that
um you know i can speak to feeling like
concerned about let's say for instance
if you feel a certain way
i think people are a lot more like
computers than we when we like to admit
and just because a lot of times i can't
parse what's going on
and why it doesn't mean that it's not it
doesn't make sense
and and i think that at least in the
times of like if i'm concerned about a
situation or about a person or about
something happening prior to
the fight or i'm like there's a reason
there was a reason i don't have to push
that down and bury it if there's a
reason like why what have i not thought
about what have i not done
what am i missing why am i feeling this
way as you mentioned
you know for yourself prior like you'd
be like why am i feeling like this i
don't do this very well in certain
aspects of my life
now that i mentioned it or not i think
about it but when it comes to competing
i think i'm doing all right job and i'm
trying to learn to be better and it's uh
and going like well why do i if i feel
this way there's a reason
okay am i thinking about this the wrong
way have i not adequately prepared for
something i have to i
have to address it and then maybe i'll
be up for four hours that night you know
like extra hours thinking what am i not
addressed watching sparring watching
this watching that
and then that when i when i
am thinking about things more more
accurately or when i've addressed what
that concern was
i feel any of that concern kind of
dissipate and
i guess uh if i honestly thought that
you know i guess when it comes to i know
i'm going to die at a certain point
obviously i'm going to get hurt
i mean you know pain happens but the
pain of
loss would be nothing compared to the or
the pain of injury nothing compared to
the pain of
of running away you know and yeah and
so i guess if i think about where's my
value what it's like
i feel like i'm a winner and every
single time i step into that ring and
fight with everything that i have i
can't promise that i'll win
my next fight i know that i have the
skills and the tools to beat anyone
in grappling or wearing mixed martial
arts at this point it's just
i i know that for certain i've trained
with enough people i compete enough
people i know i know
where i stand but i also know that i'm
not perfect and also the the better
fighter even if i perceive that i was
that thing
um doesn't win on the night the the man
who fights better
wins on the night and if i give credence
in my mind to
only the person that's that's one has
value versus going what's your process
what's your path through this how are
you going about this how are you
thinking about this how are you behaving
then if if i can focus on the process
then then i
will respect my opponent and i will
respect myself and i'll respect anyone
that behaves with with a certain level
of consistency to that
and they could win there's plenty of
winners in history that that are
bags and there's plenty of losers
that are not but
winning doesn't make you a bad or good
person and losing doesn't make you good
by default either
or bad by the fault so and i think that
that can be the truth socially that can
be the truth you know athletically and
you know
academically so i guess is there a
primal fear though like a primal
fear of getting hurt the
running away and not facing
the the threat long term is the bigger
pain
than any pain you can experience in the
fight
that's pretty powerful
you